all right michelle
michelle where'd you grow up where are
you from originally well i was born in
anaheim california at age 13 i was
i did move to minnesota um northern
minnesota i'm at 18 i came back to
california
so back and forth since then i got
married then so and
how was your childhood my childhood was
very um
i guess i was born in a wealthy a
wealthy family so it was boring to some
but to me it was regular
um i had a very abusive childhood as
well you know sexually um
i guess i was raised um in anaheim until
like i said 10 10 by nanny
i met my mom when i was nine and a half
because um i started my period so i was
allowed to
meet her because i was growing up now um
from ages three to nine my grandfather
and i had
sexual um neosexual um activities
between two of us
like like i said because i was
homeschooled i didn't know that that was
inappropriate
so i just i when i run into the house
i'd run to his room because it was
something that felt good
it was attention that i was getting from
someone other than my nanny um
so i would go in there and you know he
never penetrated me it was all
you know external but i had i had a good
feeling when i was with him so
i didn't know it was you know a wrong
unhealthy feeling but to me it was all
right
um that stopped when i was nine only
because i started my period so
um then i felt too you know too grinding
sit on grandpa's lap no more
um so i was
like i said i didn't know that there was
other opportunities in life i didn't
know that
people waited for things or wanted
things or needed things i always had
everything i was
my family or air boeing airlines so um
i have unlimited amount of money i
didn't know that there was poor people i
didn't know
that they're rich people i just knew
there was us so you come from a wealthy
family yes
yeah um um i had this i have an eyebrow
account right now
i'm blocked out of it due to my
addiction but you know i i have access
if i decide to you know do something
correct but
i'd rather be doing what i'm doing than
have to answer to or give someone else
the
credit for doing something for me that
are you know blatantly just
they're totally not humble at all they
just do it out of grade you know um
see i am i ended up graduating high
school when i was 16.
um i didn't i didn't go to school out
here the reason we moved to minnesota
was because
excuse me i was going into um junior
high
and at that point because of sats and
stuff they they recommend you go to
school and not be homeschooled
so i my mom didn't want me to be around
any black people
so her and her husband took me to
minnesota
um we got up there and things your mom
is black my mom everybody's wiping me
so you you were adopted no um that's a
whole different thing my mother
tells me or told me for many many years
that um
i was a product of rape that's what she
said now
supposedly she her and her husband were
in texas and um she went to a massage
parlor
because they were fighting and she
doesn't remember but supposedly or
coincidentally had sex with gentlemen of
color so
that's what i'm supposed to be proud of
now jumping ahead
41 years i just found out that i'm not
african-american i'm black japanese
my mother is german texavakian my father
as i found out after he passed away is
japanese
i found that out due to my daughter my
daughter is the spit image of his
daughter
so we looked at those p at the the
coincidence and we didn't you know until
that time think anything was possible my
children had blue eyes
light brown hair you know don't look
nothing of african descent at all
so we did blood tests and i'm actually a
i could say dark-skinned
um japanese um so you don't have i mean
there's african-american in me
you know past in his descendants
like in my father's descendants but he
himself does not appear to be black
your father's my father is japanese
japanese yes he um
he's darker skinned but he's not dark
like me okay my mother you know
um so we assumed i was african-american
nothing of any type of you certainly
look like you would be african
exactly and i think a lot of it has to
do with perceptions you know
the color of your skin is what somebody
else perceives you as because you know
you could be
and what do you perceive yourself as a
woman i mean i don't look at color i
don't like the color of race because
great answer i grew up with so much my
mother was a german nazi so
i i envy those that have the the
inability to see outside of their circle
you know i'm very i'm very broad i'm not
brought at all i'm very very out and
open about anything um
so i can say like
okay so growing up you know you go
through school and you write bio
autobiographies about yourself and who
you are and where you came from and all
that and i always had to
put you know my mom is my mom says i
this and then one
one year she told me that um um my
father played for utah jazz
and his name is roy wilkinson and so one
day i
i ran home said mommy i found my daddy i
found my daddy you know i found his card
and she looked at me like i was crazy
and she she didn't remember lying to me
like that so she didn't really
know why i was coming to see him i see
what i was gonna say to her
so um when i showed her she started
laughing at me and i'm like why are you
laughing that's my dad she goes
we'll talk later when you grow up
michelle and then that was the end of
that um
i was 14 at that time so i felt i was
grown up enough to hear the truth um i
never
like i said tell a year ago knew the
truth um it was always lie after lie
now i don't think my mother actually
knew that
mike was my father because of my color i
think she also was very ignorant and the
fact that
to look any further than us i suppose
opposed to sexual encounter
she was assumed because it was like more
likely that that was my father than
him due to color that was ignorance
though you know that wasn't because
she didn't want her or couldn't find out
she just didn't care i think
um so your father did play for the jazz
or no that was a lie
okay yes um that was i don't think my
mother even realized that that was a
professional person i think she might
have heard the name and just threw out
to me because i was asking too many
questions
so i was like let me just get this kid
to shut up and i'm going to say this and
she'll go about her business which i did
then you know like i said i stumbled
across the card thinking i was oh i saw
that again
i was slapped in the face again um with
my childhood my
my mother's family like i said is german
czechoslovakian
um we came into boeing airlines because
like a descendant of
my mother's father had flew over the
first crop duster
from czechoslovakia i guess that's where
it started i'm not sure but that's where
our our um relationship with boeing
started
um so um growing up i mean like i said
growing up i didn't need four one four
have anything i didn't wipe my own booty
till i was like nine or ten years old
you know um because i can properly do it
you know there's just there's it could
be done
right you know right way in the wrong
way um and they had no patience in
teaching you or
you know like i didn't have no um
no no no knowledge of i guess i want to
say normal life but
i was a very sheltered but i didn't know
a sheltered until i came out you know
like
i didn't think there was anything odd
about my situation because i did i've
been homeschooled i didn't see any other
situations
so where i was was totally fine with me
i didn't know
now like i said um being so sheltered i
gained weight all my life i was heavy
all my life um
i was always a big kid um
it didn't bother me but it seemed to
bother everybody else i didn't know
you know the difference like i said when
i was in in homeschool to me i was me
there was me and a lady named sharon
calvin who was my nanny
um um i got all the 439 pounds before i
lost any weight
um and i thought i thought i was just a
big person i was happy i was flexible i
was mobile i didn't have any limitations
i didn't have no physical i have no
health problems i never um
i don't i didn't let it limit me because
it was all my life so i gradually grew
into it i was okay with it you know my
physical
abilities were not limited by it um
but i guess it was a point where
it was just um try something different
you know
um i went back and forth i went okay
when i was in minnesota
i ended up going to college i graduated
high school i went to college i
graduated college i'm an lvn
um i've worked as a cna i have not
worked as an lvn
um i'm in college of course a lot of
caucasian people um i speak
i say a lot i think caucasian because
white is just their skin like i found
out japanese is just
my my race not my color so um
i um i got to know a lot of them in the
sports and i've not come to find out
they um
how they stay so skinny all that was
through crystal meth and so
you know at this point now remember i'm
just coming really into the world and
seeing things other than my family so
it's interesting to me i didn't know um
i didn't know that you know i didn't i
didn't ever explore what it does to you
i didn't
i mean i'm in minnesota so up there you
don't see like there's no tents and
there's no there's nobody like there is
out here
in this in this um situation so to me it
didn't do nothing wrong to nobody nobody
lost anything nobody was losing
people are still in school so it was
just a functional thing or something
they did like drink alcohol or you know
smoke a cigarette it just was something
they did and um
my mother had gave me on fifteen
thousand dollars to go buy a car
and i'm so i went over to grand forks
north dakota to buy a car
and i bought a car
um in the process i ended up buying into
one of my friends and we ended up
going and buying some crystal from that
day forward i um
did nothing but by crystal um my car
started at eleven thousand dollars
and there's a this little locket called
the limit law
and if it's seven days you can bring it
back a return okay exchange for cash
the new card i did that six times until
my car was only a value of 2700
because i continued to get cash back so
i could buy more dough um
within this time span of six months i
literally sat in a closet
um smoked crystal meth drank sprite and
ate skittles
because i had to do something my mouth
would go like it would stop i couldn't
open the shutter because it just gets
stiff from just
holding the pipe and i was smoking our
light bulbs so i just you know sat there
and got high
um bathed when i felt it was necessary
but i really didn't care
um i was trying to get skinny because
everybody was accepted you know
i guess i kind of jumped ahead but at 18
i got married
um to a caucasian man because of my
family i didn't want my children to go
through what i wanted let me go back how
much weight did you lose
216 pounds in how long about six months
you lost 216 pounds in six months yes um
the only
backlash that i had from that was when i
went to treatment
three days after treatment i almost died
of being full of a bowel because
my my um my my bowels shut down i didn't
have no more
muscle so all my food was just building
up in my stomach and i looked like i was
nine months pregnant
um i almost died they got me in like
they said if i had to wait another five
six hours it would have my everything
would have ruptured and i would have
died literally full [ __ ]
so i don't know you know it was it was
um
i don't know you look at the weigh in
your options and it worked out good for
me but it may not work out good for the
neck so it's not something that i would
ever
you know say do because it's not
necessarily i was in a very high
um like a very good place like if it
happened out here they might not come to
you fast enough you know you may
your life end over something as simple
as your ways you know it's not not worth
it
um so you got married yeah i got married
at 18.
um to a white man named robert self
and um he um
i did it because they wanted me to do it
it was something i was so used to being
as
if that it really wasn't hard to do i
did what you know made sure that
everything around me was okay
and everyone thought everything was okay
because as long as everything from
everyone from the outside but the end it
was all right
it didn't matter what michelle was doing
you know um
i've learned over the years i've been
coming to i was depressed i have high
anxiety because of my situation
i um him and i i was only with him to
have
my kids my mother um did not want me
or i don't believe would have accepted
my children in any other situation
you know being by faster children or you
know especially from a colored person so
um i said um you know i did what i did
um he was cool
um he was square you know he was north
carolina
i ended up getting pregnant with my son
um
prior to our marriage actually um we got
married while i was pregnant in thiever
falls minnesota
um my mom would not let me have the baby
out of wedlock so
i got married now my son was born june
25th in 1998.
um i had my daughter in november 5th
1999.
in october 31st of 2000 i came home from
a party at my college and my sister told
me
that she slept with my husband so i went
upstairs and i asked robert and he said
no
i said you need to get out you lied to
me it wasn't so much that he did it it
was that he lied to me
because now i can't trust you so i had
to let him go
um it was easier than i thought it would
be because i really didn't want to it
was you know the attachment was our
children
at this time our kids are one and two um
you know that's when i went to the the
activities that i i mentioned before
with the crystal meth because now i
needed to be accepted by somebody else
and i was like this is obese weight and
i was not pretty to myself so that was
anyone else to accept me i have two kids
i you know um i have everything i need
financially but that wasn't
what i wanted so um
i don't know we uh got divorced whatever
he went on about his business um
from that i guess i could say from that
point on i could really say
i don't know i don't because my death
wasn't really that bad i i went to
treatment like i said i went to
treatment after that went to treatment
for six months
um got into a halfway house at that time
i was getting my kids back my kids would
come to me every weekend
um there's an exit plan when you go to
programs and i exited my exit plan said
i was coming back california
because i felt sheltered out there now
that i had um
come out my marriage and i had been in
the world now it's only been what 10
years that i've actually been free i
guess you could say
to where i'm learning other other
activities can happen like
anxiety you know being anxious and
asking for and and looking for something
and
even wondering those those feelings i
never had as a child because i didn't
have to i always it was just
you know cater to me so those feelings
to me were interesting they were
and as i find out they're normal so it
was part of me that i
was like mad that i was not allowed to
be a normal person so now i want to be
normal
i was coming back to california with my
children
my mother like i said did not raise me
so she is envious of me having the
ability to raise my kids
she at that time went to those services
and had my kids taken from me
because she did not want them to come
out here
um
[Music]
the story she told him was true
[Music]
i do not have suitable housing
for my children as far as the state was
concerned but i had a place for my
children
um we were going to come back to
california and stay with
my stepfather
he had a three bedroom apartment but the
bedrooms were not adequate
because there was already two females in
a male living there
and i was bringing two females and two
males at the time or two females and a
male at the time and it wasn't suitable
enough to have
legal sleeping arrangements so my mom
went in court
so then um i guess you said i said [ __ ]
it
i gave up
um my mom had bought me a car
i went to um minneapolis minnesota
it's mccrack i don't know what made me
told me it was something i had knowledge
of because my treatment program you know
where to go and you know what was
available but
i said why not you know um
within two weeks of starting to smoke my
car was gone
because i had rented it out and loaned
it out to people that were dope dealers
or whatever and
they ended up blowing my engine at that
time my mom
had been called by the by the coroner's
office to come identify a body
that was found in the back seat of my
car
an hour before she was going to leave i
had called her to send me some more
money
and um she picked up the phone and um
this i called from the salvation army
and i she picked up the phone and i told
her like my mom she like
started screaming and i'm like what it
says michelle she's like oh my god
you're not dead and i'm like dead you
know
the whole concept of me actually losing
my life because of this addiction wasn't
reality and then my mom said she had
been called by the coroner's office to
come identify a body that was found in
the backseat of my car
it should have hit me then that i need
to stop but it just kind of made me
laugh
like good i'm putting you through hell
now you know like it was like that was
my payback and um
so from there i just wowed out um i
ended up coming back to california
because i just i have i have a lot of
self-morals and respect for myself and
for my family so i was too close to them
i didn't want my kids to see it
so i came back to california um
i don't know i i got jobs i had a job
after job you know i'm educated i i
could get
jobs but it was just boring to me it was
enough wasn't happening because i was
going through so much about losing my
children
um when i did i got my tubes tight after
my daughter
mind you she um was born 99 so
that's supposed to create sterilization
well
i'll let you know in a minute that that
doesn't work
um i'm i'm right now three and a half
months pregnant you know and um
i'm 42 years old it's crazy you know
and using drugs and living in a tent so
i look at it like a why me thing but
i forget it as another chance um i also
i don't know i'm kind of jumping around
i can't i also i've been in prison seven
times
um my first first my first huh before um
it started out with drugs because my
relationships were drug dealers
and they always put into my head that i
don't ever say nothing against them so
when the cops would come it was me
my first incarceration was 2002 i was
threatened with 3 13 years i ended up
getting two years
that was when it started i had the
number for 14 years
i did six terms and one violation
my most recent release from prison was
may 28
of 2019. um and my most recent
release from county was april or april
10th of
2020. um i can say now i'm actually
reporting i'm doing things
other than my sobriety correctly i'm you
know i'm no longer running from the
police which is the first time since
2002.
um so something is waking up in me i
think it might be the pregnancy i'm not
sure
um your other arrests were for what kind
of stuff okay well all of them are drugs
i have now recently
my latest ones were um grand theft auto
i run into stores and um
grab items um i do like louis vuitton
and gucci so one
bag got to make grand theft and put me
in prison for three years so boosting
yes yeah which is why you're so
well-dressed yes
well you know you live on skid row yeah
well because churches drop this stuff
off and i'm like might as well use it
you know and
and um you're living in a tent i live in
actually i live
yeah i live in a tent and it's not even
really a tent it was it's a it's a
screened-in patio for a tent i didn't
know that when i bought when i got it
but it's large you know i accumulate
stuff from the from the streets like
everybody else does um churches and
people they help us
out here bring stuff you know i got a
bed i've got a couch i've got everything
that you would
ask for i guess you could say except for
normalcy in so many ways but then to me
this is okay and i don't know if that
sounds right but i'm okay right now i'm
um
i'm not satisfied but i'm okay you know
boosting is how you support yourself now
yeah um i i used i i was i've worked as
a prostitute until i was 30
but i got raped at 30 and i didn't want
i don't think it was worth my life
it was a scary scary thing and it was
raped outside of see now let me rewind
but
prior to that i was getting raped
molested through family members and and
different people but at that time i
didn't know it was wrong so i was more
submissive and it wasn't painful it
didn't hurt my mind
it because it was a good feeling in the
end because what happened with your
grandfather
yeah exactly and because i was never
told it was wrong
because i was never i never brought the
situation up because why talk about
something that was positive to me you
know it wasn't like oh daddy did this or
grandpa did this it just it was part of
my day you know
now when i went to treatment i found out
that all that now mind you this is
20 years later i find out that i was
abused
i was confused abused how i felt good so
i had to go through that whole thing
now when i finally accept that i was
abused which sounds crazy but i finally
accept that this person did something
wrong to me
now he's passed away okay the other
people that have done it
are still around but i ask for you know
i
i forgive them on my own confidence just
for my own self you know for me
to be okay they say do that so you're
okay doesn't matter about them it's for
you
so i did it i did it basically just to
keep them quiet because i really didn't
still to this they don't feel
that i was hurt you know so it's kind of
i don't know it's funny but
because of that when i got raped and
because i was told it was such a
horrible thing
now when it happens i'm just devastated
like i really just feel like a piece of
trash because it only happens to people
that are probably you know
and i i put myself in that place and it
wouldn't happen if i didn't do it and
so it was all about me again so i put
through
through that the talon to where i
willingly jumped into cars and willingly
gave myself over for a few dollars
now if i jump in the car i'm robbing
them because now i'm mad at them
i've got anger because they tried they
took something for me i don't care if it
was that man it was these men
and i put them in a category which isn't
healthy but it's reality and that's what
i do
so i'll get them for everything they got
and i don't care about the backlash just
because i feel like they did to me i'm
due to them i live with that every day
and
so far i've made it you know i mean sure
things happen but i'm still alive and
i can move forward with that um
i recently well
my daughter was 15 so five years ago i
go on facebook a lot
and one day i just decided to look for
my daughter um and i found her christmas
on christmas day
in 2015 and we
we talked on facebook now mind you
um she's adopted they both got adopted
so
they're not supposed to talk to me um my
daughter actually got in trouble
i feel bad for this day but at the time
it was a blessing to me
um she got trouble she had to shut off
her page and her mother and father you
know
grounded her now when i got out of
prison in 2019
i contacted my daughter again i
also was looking for my son
i come to find out that my son
he's having a memory of something
happening to him when he was a child
that didn't occur in my life
or didn't occur when he was with me but
they're telling him it was with me when
he was with me
because um for whatever reason
whoever did this to him
is once again trying to tear us apart
but he remembers being locked in closets
and stuff like this and um
by some man the only man that was ever
in my life was my husband so
um now i'm being getting knowledge that
he was abused in his foster in his
in his home um
i have been able to find him
but uh you'll be okay
um my daughter's in college my son
supposedly has the company now
my mother um is still around
but i didn't really say in the beginning
but everybody is still
okay with how they are um they're not
open-minded
um and money is all that they care about
so i come out here
just get real because i could be me
for the most part um
nobody tells you what you have to do
when you have to do it i
don't know how much you have to be
nobody really there's nobody really no
rules
there's respect and there's common
knowledge but there's no real rules
about being homeless um especially down
here because we get everything we want
and you know but um
so i'm here to get rid i hate money and
um i i receive it wonderfully
but i also give it wonderfully because
having it i know having it doesn't make
you happy
from experience to this day i know that
the more i have the more miserable i am
unless somebody lets me help them with
it
even if it's getting high if it's
getting something to eat
if it's burning it i'll burn money
because it makes me so angry to have for
so long
um and it irritates me so bad that
people get so mad that i spend it
so freely but why not it comes freely
like really it does
and so i don't know i i you know i've
been down here
since 2007 on and off
outside of my incarcerations i return
here when i get out
um and
i just feel that i'm where i'm at
because i need to be where i'm at
um and i just you know
i've just realized that you know just
because of your your your
geographical situation or your you know
your society
your what your economic status in
society
that's not who you are that's just where
you are you play in a place that you're
at
and who you are is who you are from the
beginning all the way to the end as far
as anything goes
it could be a religion it could be the
gangs that you try to be in or all these
things they're all just
road maps to who they want you to be and
so i've just been able to become who i
not necessarily want to be but have
become so i i'm
i guess in a sick kind of way you can
say i'm i'm i'm satisfied because
i think i've encountered a lot more
things and i've made it past
a lot more obstacles and setbacks than a
majority of people because i'm
willing to go backwards to go forward
you know
all the negativity that's come in my
life i'm okay with
because without that i got stronger you
know and so today i have the strength
because of those things so i'm grateful
not to the person but to the experience
um and i believe that began when i was a
kid because of my
ignorance and the fact that sexual abuse
was hindering
i didn't use it as hindrance i use it as
an advantage so
that at age three allowed me to become
42 with the strength that
nothing's going to eliminate me but
myself you know um
in any sense at all um i didn't say this
at first and i guess i totally forgot
because it's really i'm saying i've
put it to my my hindsight because i have
terminal cancer and
that to me is just a it's like a piece
of change in my pocket because it's just
what i carry around with me it's not
what i
am um i deal with it more when i'm
incarcerated because they make me do
chemo
that's where i feel like i'm dying when
i'm out here i don't i feel fine
because i'm under the influence first of
all and secondly because um
i'm not no restraints or forces i don't
do my treatment out here
you know now when i found out i was
pregnant um i can't do chemo either
um my my cancer is bone marrow so
what happens i just become really numb
my body doesn't
move how i think it should move because
it doesn't know
to move i'm telling myself to but it's
kind of basically paralyzed
i'm supposed to be in a wheelchair right
now they've given me two dates and i've
surpassed both of them
and as funny as it seems my doctor said
it's because i'm an addict
because crack cocaine allows me to have
an artificial
stimulant to be mobile because you take
a hit your body just goes
into a supernatural place you know like
where you can just go even if you don't
wanna you're gonna go like you don't
care what you look like how you
where you are who sees you you're gonna
go because that's just what it's said to
do
so he also he told me you know
this is even prior to my pregnancy i i
have to choose crack or chemo
because both of them raise my blood to
my body temperature
which if i'm doing both it could cause
me to have a brain aneurysm
because my blood will boil so i chose
crack
and he said i was the fourth person that
he has had in his
um queso that has lived longer or
benefited from their addiction
of crack okay not that he has anything
else of crackle cane because
of the ability of having like you could
say a heart a jump start
instead of having to do it yourself my
body doesn't work as hard because i'm
taking i'm taking this hit and it's
giving me energy like a boost like a red
bull
or an energy drink we give it gives you
artificial energy that's what this crack
does for me it allows me to
be mobile without having to really work
at it
so like i said the cancer is not me
it's just change in my pocket and i feel
it'll be spent sooner or later and it'll
be
also taken away from me so and i found
out about that in 2014
because my thyroid stopped so
you know just another advantage in my
life is to get past another hurdle
and you know see how much longer i can
go i don't think i'm gonna i don't think
i have
i think i'm a lot longer to live
unfortunately sometimes i think that but
other times it's like go to sleep
michelle and don't wake up and you'll be
just fine but then i don't think that i
will because what else haven't i done
you know good or bad so you know um
what do you think the most important
lesson you've learned
to stay open-minded to not be secluded
and don't don't don't
don't don't close your mind off to
anything because there's so much out
there and
oh anything anything that happens to you
never let a setback
hold you back don't ever let a seatbelt
stay on you know you have to take it off
and get out the car right so take off
that the hindrance and just walk forward
because
that's giving that situation the power
over you so you're no longer in
control so as egotistical and as
prideful as
as humans are if we allow that one
situation to
slow us down then you're letting that
person control you i don't no one
controls me we want to say
so don't let that situation control you
just keep going forward because there's
going to be another one
you have to get past it when you stop
that's your choice nobody can choose for
you and nobody can make
a decision for you unless you allow them
to you know as hard as that is and as
easy as it sounds i guess
maybe that's why it's so hard to do you
know because it's so easy
you know all right michelle well thank
you so much for
sharing your interesting story thank you
thank you
you